i've given up trying to advise anybody
on on who's terrible in in the
government that's really a matter for
the prime minister all i'm going to say
is that
we are absolutely determined to get to
the bottom of uh what went wrong and how
we can help in the future because we've
seen two issues here today the first is
as you rightly identified there uh an
issue with intelligence the foreign
office's own principal risk report
highlighted in july on the 22nd of july
the risk of complete failure in
afghanistan
and now we're seeing even now people who
didn't make it out in time so there's a
there's a lesson to be learned there now
there's an ongoing question as to how on
earth do we help those who are entitled
to our protection and our help now who
find themselves through no force of
their own cut-off isolated and alone in
an extremely hostile country and so we
will push we're pushing on all of that
as well yeah obviously very pressing
matter there this principal risk report
that that you mentioned in your
questioning it doesn't appear to be in
in the public domain um how how did you
obtain it
uh i've spoken to a lot of people in the
last few weeks who are very keen that i
should understand exactly what's been
going on inside uh the foreign office
and inside other elements of government
and i've been extremely careful as you
can imagine in which bits of information
i use and which bits i don't in order to
protect
absolutely the security of our nation
and those areas where we do need to be
cautious but i think in a warning like
this which clearly has now been well
overtaken by events revealing that it
was made on the 22nd july is a matter of
public interest
so are you saying this was a leaked
report is it from a whistleblower
it's a report given to me by somebody
who was in a position to know
okay but it is now out there in in the
public domain that this report existed
it doesn't speak well does it to the
systems of intelligence that are feeding
into the foreign secretary if he didn't
seem to be aware of it you are aware of
it and now the whole country knows about
it well it's uh quite clear that there
are two kinds of intelligence failures
there are those failures where the
intelligence agency fails to provide the
intelligence and that's the traditional
meaning of the word and there's a second
kind of intelligence failure where
whoever is the principal didn't read it
i'm afraid you can't blame the spies if
the uh if the officers don't read the
report okay so questions uh further
questions there for the the foreign
secretary um
he didn't seem to have much confidence
about the numbers of people who are
still there who should have been
evacuated he's not in touch with some of
the ambassadors in in third countries
and whose borders that could have been
used to get to get people out and he's
admitted that the afghan staff who were
guarding the uk embassy didn't manage to
get out either
do you think that the foreign office do
you have any confidence in the foreign
office or the foreign secretary
specifically to get those people out
well there's a lot of us uh funnily
enough actually there's a bunch of
ex-military uh folk officers and uh and
other ranks who are currently organizing
to help various individuals um some of
you may have heard that i've one of the
interpreters who worked with me when i
was still serving uh has got stuck i can
i can i'm very pleased to be able to
report that others have got out and
we've had some very good cooperation
with some amazingly dedicated foreign
office personnel in the region and some
extraordinarily courageous uh people
around the world and that has helped us
to get people out i should also say uh
that we've been in pretty regular touch
um with various ministers and um you
know we are able to get some cooperation
and get ministers helping and i'm very
pleased to say that emphasis has been
there so i think there's an awful lot
that we can all do um and and that's
where we're focused
um
he mentioned several times about the
priority of getting people out and there
seems to be this hierarchy of in which
order they were going to attach the
priority he mentioned several times this
phrase mono nationals
was that new to you is there a degree of
britishness which ascribes to you some
kind of priority for getting out of
afghanistan is that something that
you're comfortable with
it was a surprise to me i've only ever
had one belief which is either you have
a british passport in which case you're
entitled to protection
of the british state or you don't in
which case you need to have
justification for that protection uh
we've already established that those who
are interpreters or
maybe guards of the british embassy or
so on may be entitled to that protection
despite not being british citizens but
if you are a british citizen
i don't think it matters what other
passport you may or may not hold
we owe you a duty of care you're one of
us uh and
and so we should absolutely be treating
all british citizens of whatever uh
whatever other citizenships they may
hold as one so will you be taking that
up further then with the foreign office
there are a series of follow-on
questions that you're beginning to
identify that many of us have picked up
on during that session there will be a
series of follow-up letters and we'll
make those public and due course and i
was just going to say would you like to
tell us what any of those other
follow-up questions are now
i've got to clear them with the rest of
the committee first so it wouldn't be
polite of me to share them before i've
done that oh first for breaking news
here at sky um
given that you've just
given that you've just said you know the
spies can create this intelligence but
if if the ministers don't read it then
there's not much we can do about that
can we even be in a position to be
talking about uh you know targeting uh
terrorist cells targeting isis
talking to the taliban about getting
people out of there if we've got
ministers who don't read the
intelligence
well i think uh it's a little bit too
far to say that i'm saying that
ministers don't read the intelligence
what i'm saying is that intelligence has
to be assessed and read at each level up
the chain
and now whether or not it's then
included in a major package or not or
whether it's it's seen separately is
it's that's where that's where the
challenge comes and but i'm absolutely
confident that uh for targeting
authorities i know because i used to be
uh
tangentially involved in it that reading
the intelligence is exactly what um the
permanent joint headquarters and the
chief joint aspirations uh do and just
by the response that we saw from pghq
and admiral
key and his extraordinary team we can
see that the the ministry of defense and
particularly military commitment in it
were absolutely all over this
um i know that you were on television
this morning and warning against uh
talks serious talks with
with the taliban who you described as a
as a terror death cult i think you said
um how do we go about getting
evacuees out
without dealing with them
well i i'm afraid we are going to have
to deal with them that's true um because
that's the reality of of defeat if you
are defeated you don't get to choose who
your opposite number is the the victors
do that and in this case uh it's the
taliban we chose to deal with um the
afghan government but they don't exist
anymore uh so our choice doesn't matter
i'm afraid that's simply what defeat
looks like so we do have to deal with
the taliban but i think we need to do it
with open eyes and i think that the
foreign secretary shared my concern
today i think it was one of those
moments where although he didn't make
the comment it was perfectly obvious
what he thought the reality is that
we're dealing with an organization that
claims
through its amazingly slick pr operation
some of the images of which you're
seeing at the moment claims to have
reformed claims to now sort of respect
the rights of individuals and so on in
various different ways but in reality
it's
even now not just denying uh women and
girls education or a place in work or
further education but it's actually
doing much more than that it's actually
hunting people down i i know of people
in lashkar and kandahar have been
reported to me
as having been murdered in recent days
and weeks
and i'm told of friends in kabul who are
moving house to house at the moment in
order to stay one step ahead
of those who are chasing them you spoke
very movingly in the house of commons a
short while ago i'm just wondering uh
some time on from that have your
reflections
changed in any way about what has been
lost and indeed if there is any chance
and you were indicating that there is
some still some chance that you could
try and take something out of this
situation do you still hold that view
oh look i do i'm incredibly positive for
the united kingdom in in coming years
and decades the reality is that this
feels like defeat because in afghanistan
it is a defeat but it isn't necessarily
a defeat uh for the uk or indeed for the
west more widely the reality is we are
an incredibly uh powerful nation and i
don't just mean militarily but powerful
because of the culture because of the uh
the the because of the freedoms that we
enjoy and the fact that you're grilling
me like this uh today as part of that
example and but the fact that i was able
to grill
a cabinet minister as part another part
of that example you know these liberties
are what people choose just look at the
migration flows in the world people want
to come to free countries they want to
start businesses where there's the rule
oh
you know they want to grow their
families and their enterprise in areas
where they can have a relatively
predictable future so i'm hugely
positive for the united kingdom but what
we need to do is we need to remember
that actually we have these strengths
and we can use them we need to believe
in ourselves and we need to partner with
allies and others around the world to
make sure that we actually deploy the
force that we have at the moment we are
allowing ourselves to be defeated we're
backing away from afghanistan we're
we're hiding away from china in
different ways you know we are finding
ourselves on the back foot when there is
literally no need to be and and from
what we've learned over the last
week the last few hours um would you say
that we are at significantly greater
risk of terror attack on uk soil
well there is one thing that we have uh
demonstrated time and again over the
last two or three decades whenever an
islamist
radical extremist group like the taliban
takes over a piece of territory whether
that piece of territory is in northern
nigeria or mali or libya uh you know
syria iraq i mean i can keep going what
always follows what always follows is
exactly the same a terrorist group that
seeks to export that violence that
radical form of
terrorism that extremist view it always
tries to export that violence and we see
sadly incidents uh across not just the
uk but around the world most of those
incidents normally happen in the region
and many many people innocent people are
killed but they also come as close as
this and in fact from the window that i
can see in front of me um there was an
attack not very long ago where somebody
inspired by the the death cult of isis
came and killed an incredibly
brave police officer who was defending
our parliament and our democracy
um i know that you have talked and you
just have done about the need for
collaborative foreign policy the dangers
of perhaps just hitching our wagon onto
the united states did you think from the
evidence you heard from the foreign
secretary that that is a view that the
government is coming to as well
well to be fair we didn't really get
into that because that's the sort of
that's the next stage of the questions
we were very much focused on what went
wrong in afghanistan and what we can do
to help those in most need but you know
i'm going to be pushing again for our
european nato partners to take up more
of the burden now the united states have
had a point on this which is not all of
our partners have always been
pulling their own weight
and we need to we need to make sure that
we we all do
but it's also important that the uk
reaches out and makes sure that we do
exactly what we should be which is the
network power that enabling cog if you
like between different sized countries
because we have demonstrated over
operations in iraq and afghanistan and
indeed
right around the world that we can
partner with huge countries like the
united states and much smaller countries
like estonia and make and get the best
out of both now we should be doing that
not just for european countries or north
atlantic countries but also for
countries uh in uh africa and indeed in
asia who wish to work with us and who
wish really to have the option to turn
their people towards the freedom and
democracy that we enjoy that are
currently feeding the pressure of
autocracy and tyranny either
from countries like beijing or russia or
indeed from
the islamic theology islamists sorry
theology that we are seeing emerging
again in afghanistan